-Our next guest is an
Emmy-nominated sports journalist
and lead sideline reporter
for "Fox NFL Sunday."
Please welcome back
to the show
our friend Erin Andrews,
everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back!
I am so happy you're here.
I mean, anyone who watches
football knows that on Sunday
you were in terrible weather
in Cleveland, Ohio.
And now look at you.
It's like you --
Had no idea.
-You know,
a ton of undergarments
that suck you in.
And the baseball hat's gone.
And there we go. Yeah.
-It was a very --
It was terrible weather,
but it was
a very exciting game and --
-Let's be honest.
It wasn't that bad of weather.
I mean, it was on-and-off rain.
I love a weather report.
What would you do
if you weren't doing this?
-You would do the weather?
-I would love to work
for the Weather Channel
or Fox Weather.
Yeah.
I would love to do that.
I love miles-per-hour
wind gusts.
[ Laughter ]
I love, like, rain throughout.
That wasn't that funny.
But I love, like, you know,
the rain throughout the game.
-It wasn't funny.
It was shocking.
-Oh.
-I don't think anybody's
ever heard someone be like,
"I mean, who doesn't love
miles-per-hour wind gusts?"
-Right.
17-to-18-mile-per-hour winds
we were dealing with yesterday.
-I will say
17-to-18-mile-per-hour wind --
When people say that
on the news, I always wonder,
"Now what am I supposed to do
with that information?"
Like, have you ever heard --
At what mile per hour
are you like,
"Well, I'm scrapping my plans"?
-Well, yesterday 'cause
I had to put a hat on
because, you know, you needed
the hair to be good to go.
-So at what mile per hour
do you go with hat?
-So, 17 to 18.
I thought, did it affect --
Listen.
We're paying attention.
-I know. Yes.
-You know, they missed the field
goal and all that stuff.
But the weather
wasn't that crazy.
-Gotcha.
-But it wasn't lovely.
But it's that time of year.
It's football, baby.
-You love it, right?
-Steelers.
-Do -- Steelers are fine.
-They come to LA next week.
-They do come to LA.
And I'll tell you this.
I don't know who's gonna win.
But I know there will be
more Steelers fans in LA than --
-Alright. Relax.
-I'm just telling you.
-Have you gone to SoFi yet?
-I haven't gone to SoFi.
-Oh, yeah. It's cool.
-Is it cool?
The problem is there's just --
You know, LA sports fans
are a little different.
Like, the Steelers fans
bring it.
-Okay. Well, they do.
Hey. One of my best --
We have -- This was nothing
that I talked about
with your producers.
One of my favorite
Steelers games
was Dallas at Pittsburgh.
It was Dak and Zeke's,
like, rookie season.
I remember two minutes left.
-You can stop.
-But you lost.
The towels were going.
All the lint was flying.
It was awesome. Crazy scene.
-By the way, you don't
ever have to tell me
the ending of a Steelers game.
I have a --
'Cause we went down
and scored on one of those --
Roethlisberger was gonna
fake spike. And then touchdown.
You know what? That is a very
famous game in my household.
-Why?
-Because that is the first time
my wife said,
"I don't like you after these."
-So, my dad --
massive Red Sox fan.
And I guess my parents'
relationship got a little rocky.
They're still together.
Love them. Yay! Clap for that.
[ Applause ]
But I guess --
You can figure out which
World Series moment it was.
I was a, like, young baby.
My dad took baby powder
and threw it across the room.
And my mom's like,
"You cannot behave like this."
-Oh, my God.
-Do you have a moment
in your house?
Was it that one?
-Yes, but here's --
Well, that's --
So, you're talking about '86,
for sure.
So, the one --
the bad one in our house,
which was 2003,
the Aaron Boone home run.
Now, again, the next year,
the Red Sox win
and everything's hunky-dory.
-Yes.
-But my mom is only a sports fan
because of my dad
and her two boys, right?
And so she's become
a huge sports fan
and she cares
more than any of us.
And when Aaron Boone
hit the home run,
she stood up and --
according to my dad -- said,
"This is all the fault of you
and those mother [bleep] boys."
[ Laughter ]
-Of course it is.
It is your fault.
-That's a mind-boggling
sentence to say, though.
-Well. Traumatizing.
How's the PTSD from that one?
-As with everything
in our family,
we pretend
like it never happened.
-Yeah, exactly.
-Now, you have a very --
Obviously,
I'm not breaking news here
that one of the biggest fans...
-Wow.
-Usually a fan does not affect
an NFL season like this.
-Right.
-But Taylor Swift, who --
credit where credit's due --
in August,
you and your podcast host...
-Yep. Charissa Thompson. Yep.
-You and Charissa
basically said to --
You basically threw it out
to the universe,
and you thought Travis
should go on a date.
-Have you met him?
-Yes. He's wonderful.
-He's great. Right?
-He's wonderful.
She's wonderful.
I totally understand
why you guys thought
this would be a good match.
-Yeah.
-But even more exciting,
you have an apparel line,
and this is sort of NFL gear
for the female fan.
-Yeah.
-And she wore it to a game.
Now --
-She wore it last Thursday.
Yeah. It's our --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you. Yeah.
This was big, man,
and, you know --
-I mean, I got to imagine if
you've got an apparel brand...
-If you have anything
and she puts it on.
I mean, if you own a Kleenex
company and she wipes her --
it's like -- Oh, my God!
Yes. This was a huge moment.
And, yeah, in August,
Travis was very open
about not getting to meet her.
And so we were just being really
candid because we love him.
We're good friends of his.
And we just were like,
"Taylor, date this guy.
I mean, he's good-looking."
And I can say that
'cause my husband loves him
and they've met before.
Got to be really careful where
you throw the "good-lookings."
-Yeah.
-But, yeah, he's just
such a great, great guy.
And so we threw it out there.
They got together.
Of course, we're getting
all the credit now
on the "Calm Down" podcast.
We hope to officiate
the wedding.
We hope to be there when
he proposes, all the things.
But, yeah, she put the --
she put my jacket on.
-Are you getting calls
from the warehouse being like,
"We need more staff!"?
Like, what happens?
-Yes. Yeah. Well, we restocked.
As soon as she wore it,
I saw it.
I started screaming
and freaking out
and singing all
my favorite Swiftie songs.
And then, yeah, we restocked
and we sold out.
And thank you, thank you,
Taylor Swift!
And now starting today,
we have more up on fanatics.com.
And your wife, I heard,
has the same impact
when she wears team apparel.
-She does. Yeah.
-So you know we're sending you
some Pittsburgh gear.
-That'd be great.
We're gonna get her out there.
-Flying off the shelves. Yeah.
-It'd be hard to know
what the spike
is attributable to, you know?
Is it Taylor or is it Alexi?
But, you know...
-Yeah. Exactly.
Well, we'll see. We'll compare.
I'll let you know.
-You and Charissa --
You mentioned. I do want
to hammer home again.
It's really wonderful.
You guys are old friends.
And "Calm Down" podcast
is a delight.
And it does other things
other than match-make.
It's a wonderful --
It's a wonderful podcast
where two friends talk about
what they're experts in.
And, hey, thanks so much
for being here.
-Thanks for having me.
-It's always such a pleasure.
Erin Andrews, everybody.
You can catch her every week
on "Fox NFL Sunday."
And "Calm Down" is available
wherever you get your podcasts.
Stick around. We'll be back
with music from Ryan Beatty.